actually hey I'm done I'm the director
and scriptwriter before gift which we've
just finished shooting for possibly days
so if the film is about a young boy who
uses dance to get over his fears of
users and negatives in the space to want
to fuel him to dance and to move and to
do something positive like poetry and
that's where the form is written in the
style of the poem as well at the same
time as it's almost filmed in a fairy
tale light he has made the decision to
understand that he has freedom is not
stuck in this concrete general society
beauty's a puzzler Danza a very young
boy especially the famous American
premier shipping method Thalia and the
approach respect suddenly severe anemia
damsel in allowed abundance at first it
was a violent ends but now performance
of expression
the whole story has to fill out and
everything I think the major challenge
is getting the beats right with with the
Samba for these little moments that are
gonna have a red dragon to shoot on I
chose to go with that size high speeds
of twos we just thought how are we gonna
make this journey as fantastic as
possible
you think that festivals were hard for
doing it where the roads are really
rocky and like the lots of kids running
around wanting to know what you're doing
the Baathist only use organic and
aesthetic songs so I was on site there
recording the majority of the sound
effects that are featured in an actual
film the middlee in the track that she
comes in the sauna used was a God that I
into the top of a bottle
clapping of birds finding specific about
it practically about five inhale song of
barking chickens do not to be very
audible peaches Big Ideas the expensive
ideas with no money we're just so
grateful to zt2 years who gave us their
gear for free every single person in the
township their over their homes to us
I think reward is such a great job with
what we had was such fun